hey youtubers is Charlie and there were
so many WTF moments in this week's
Walking Dead we just need to get right
in it a whole bunch of plot points were
tied off from earlier in the season and
there was a major
omage to a scene from the comic books
quick shout out to my giveaway if you're
finding me for the first time just as a
way to say thank you to all you guys for
being so awesome I'm doing a weekly
Walking Dead giveaway just for all my
review episodes all you have to do to
participate is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I'll be
announcing the winner during my Q&A
video tomorrow night we have some major
stuff to work through here so I'm gonna
do my top 5 WTF moments and then I'm
gonna do my review careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet but
here we go number 5 Lizzie's new friend
Griselda there was so much that was
wrong about this did anyone else scream
at their TV her performance the actress
that is was just a little too much but
we got the message Lizzie is batshit
crazy the best part was seeing Carol get
that look on her face the look that says
I'm so going to end up having to put
Lizzie down then the camera pans over to
Tyreese and he gets that what the [ __ ]
face it was beautiful it's pretty clear
even this soon in the episode that
Lizzie is going to be a major problem
she's gonna be the antagonist of this
episode that means that she's become a
bigger threat than the walkers running
out of food or finding the others number
4 Lizzie feeding the Walker what the f
at least we finally got a definitive
answer about who was feeding the walkers
this was so disturbing Lizzie shall make
you understand based on the scenes in
the teaser I knew she wasn't going to
get bitten or died this soon in the
episode but the minute her hand reached
out I just wanted to slap her it seems
like in her mind she's seeing all of
them as they were and just can't move
forward
developmentally she's stuck at the point
of the outbreak you know before
everything went to hell you'd think if a
walker was nearby you would do
everything you could to stay as far away
as possible
number 3 Tyreese tells Carol about his
Karen nightmares the irony of the scene
was just beautiful with Carol in the
foreground and Tyreese just going on and
on about Karen remember earlier in the
episode where he's asleep on that chair
jerking around I bet he was having a
Karen nightmare
right then I really did expect Carol to
come clean whatever she did go to speak
but I'm glad she saved the moment for
later did anyone else laugh just a
little bit when Tyreese went to hug her
and he had that gun in his hand when he
wrapped it around Carol it's like they
were saying that murder is just around
the corner which is why that next moment
that came after it was just so
appropriate number two lizzy kills her
sister she goes full-on bend and she was
about to change quote-unquote Judith -
everyone had been wondering if the girls
were going to take the place of Ben and
Billy and it went down exactly the way
it did in the comics here's the shot of
been right after killing his brother the
only difference is is that Carl was
involved in the resolution of that and
in this episode is Carol
after seeing Lizzie's character
progression this season and in this
episode I don't think there's any other
way her plot could have ended even if
they had made it to terminus together
Lizzie still would have continued doing
the same things and because her sister
was so attached to her she would have
either been killed by a walker because
of Lizzie or by Lizzie herself so unless
Lizzie had turned and been killed by
Carol or Tyreese she would have killed
her sister no matter what and my number
one WTF moment Carol kills Lizzie just
look at the flowers and count one two
three because I'd already read the
comics story I kept expecting this to
happen because the earlier killing was
so much like it was in the comics I
think they made it a little more
emotional since Carol was kind of like
their surrogate mother
I had actually expected her to shoot
Lizzie on the spot whenever she got the
gun out of her hand I wasn't a huge fan
of the transitions from that moment to
them going into the house talking about
Lizzie to Carol going and shooting
Lizzie the pace just felt a little
stop-and-go and I had hoped that Lizzy's
death would have been a little more
intense there was a lot that they chose
not to show us in the episode they
didn't show Lizzie stabbing her sister
and they didn't show the bullet hitting
Lizzie's head personally I think they
shot it that way and then AMC just made
them take it out of the episode they
made them edit it out but you can
comment on whether or not you think that
they intended to show us the actual
deaths in the end though I'm glad she's
dead if you did not hate Lizzie before
this episode then this was the last
straw I have no idea where they would
have gone with her character had she
lived and made it to terminus it was
almost like she was turning into a
crazier version of the governor I mean
think about it for a second she was
going to kill baby Judith
and when she confessed as much I just
wanted Carol to shoot her right on the
spot so one last bonus WTF moment Carol
finally confesses to Tyreese I love how
you can just see the murder on his face
as he's shaking the table with his grip
but he's wrapping his brain around it
and totally forgives her not to say that
he will ever forget
I love his quote though it's a part of
you now me too it's a big callback to
tyreese's earlier talk with Carol about
the dead talking to them and Carol's
answer that they're not haunting them
they're just reminding them of what they
have to do I think we're meant to take
away that Tyreese isn't going to harm
Carol in the future but they're never
going to be Pallas the way they might
have been had the awful things not
happened in this episode Tyreese wanted
to stay in that cottage so bad how
ironic that he said he wasn't ready to
be around people when Carol then said
Lizzie cannot be around people let it
not go and said though the thing that I
was most excited about in this episode
was baby Judith not dying as awful as
everything was that did make me happy
but now it's your turn let me know what
was your biggest WTF from the episode
you know was it the big deaths or was it
the craziness that preceded it I do have
to say each successive Lizzie moment
increased my stress levels exponentially
overall I give the episode an A for
having the guts so to speak to kill off
two major characters in a way completely
faithful to the comics with minor
exceptions for the second death as an
asterisk though I have to give Lizzie's
performance a C for acting I knew what
the actress was trying to convey she's
at the Joffrey of the episode and the
problem is is that when they're supposed
to make you hate them which they do
beautifully you end up hating them so
much that they're almost unbearable to
watch Micah's performance was a fresh
breath of sanity get your gun I would
have liked to see the deleted scene that
preceded her stabbing maybe it'll be on
the DVD maybe not but I don't think that
even HBO
would have shown a child stabbing
another child even on Game of Thrones
when Aria killed that boy in season 1
they kind of cut away really quick I'll
say that the child acting I did love in
the episode was when Micah was
comforting Lizzie the first time and
they chanted in unison it reminded me of
the creepy twin girls from The Shining
did anyone else get that vibe from them
I also really loved tyreese's
performance in the episode I almost felt
like he had the hardest job you know
aside from killing a child he had to
convey all these emotions without really
doing anything his character is not a
good communicator so a lot of his
performance
to be physical in that last scene with
Carole was just beautifully intense so
now let me know what you thought of the
episode are you happy that Lizzy's dead
even if it meant that Micah had to die
too in other news I'll be posting that
Q&A video tomorrow night all you have to
do to participate in the giveaway is be
a subscriber and leave a comment
in the meantime click here to get my
predictions for the rest of the season a
couple of those big questions that I had
were actually answered in this episode
but there's still a couple things that
haven't happened yet and click here to
get that Q&A video thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives